GUS CLASS: Hello world.
And welcome to this week's
episode of "Google+ Developers
Live." I'm Gus Class,
a developer
programs engineer on Google+.
And today joining me is a
special guest, Louis Gray.
LOUIS GRAY: I don't know if
special's the right word.
I'm here for "Google Developers
Live" all the time.
It is always my pleasure
to join you.
Especially about one of my
favorite products here at
Google, Google+.
GUS CLASS: Well it's
great to have you.
And you're always welcome
on a show.
LOUIS GRAY: Thank you, sir.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
So this is going to be an
episode covering best
practices for Google+.
And this is sort of
the third in a
series that we've started.
And if you want to have a little
preview of what we're
going to be showing today,
we'll be talking about
interactive posts and targeting
them in unique ways.
LOUIS GRAY: So interactive
posts.
Now you mentioned a second ago,
you said "best practices
for Google+." But we're not
talking about best practices
on how to use Google+, or when
the post, or when to look at
your stream, or any of those
things from the consumer side.
We're talking more on
the developer angle.
Because we are a
developer show.
That's what we do here.
So you want to talk about
interactive posts.
What are the things anyway?
They're kind of new.
Tell me more.
GUS CLASS: Yes they are.
So interactive posts-- we like
to think of them as a new way
of sharing.
So as opposed to the traditional
shares that we've
done on Google+, interactive
posts now have a call to
action, such as download,
or attack, or view
that allows you to--
LOUIS GRAY: Attack?
GUS CLASS: Attack is--
yes one of those.
LOUIS GRAY: Not attach?
GUS CLASS: Attack.
LOUIS GRAY: Attack
[INAUDIBLE].
GUS CLASS: So if you wanted to
have a call to action that
would cause users in each other
streams to attack each
other inside of your
application, this new way of
sharing allows you to directly
bring users in, and then
perform actions within
your applications.
So this is kind of new.
And we're very excited
about it.
And it's been one of the key
launch features that we had.
And it added a lot of stuff that
people were looking for.
Like being able to pre-fill
text inside of
the interactive posts.
So we're all really
excited about it.
LOUIS GRAY: I just want to
hear more about attack.
GUS CLASS: Attack, yes.
LOUIS GRAY: Hopefully
we'll get into that.
GUS CLASS: Yes this was one of
our demos that we are going to
show for I/O. Anyways, if you
remember last week, we were
talking about ways to improve
the sign in experience by
dynamically rendering scopes.
And if you take a look at the
site from last week, we can
show you that one more time.
And so what we'd started with
was kind of like a real,
conventional Sign-In button.
And we replaced it
instead with this
custom Sign-In button.
And when that renders, you get
this pop-up that allows you to
choose the scopes that you're
going to be using for the app.
So I'll turn on Google
Drive and Google+.
And then here's a consent
dialogue that's real common,
if you've ever seen
an application
that's using Google+.
And then the thing that
we'd done on the first
show happens now.
And the user's profile
information is animated, and
they're drawn into the app to
kind of have that emotional
connection.
So by rendering the scopes
dynamically inside of the
Sign-In button, you're able to
draw more users to sign in for
your app, because they're able
to trust this application, and
the things that they're
sharing with you.
And then, by rendering that
profile in a unique way, and
drawing the user's eye to it,
and welcoming them once they
come back into your
applications, you're able to
build that emotional
connection.
Which is something that
social is all about.
LOUIS GRAY: Now you talked
pretty quick through that
concern dialogue.
As fast as I've seen it
in here in a while.
So what is it exactly that
Google+ is asking
for in terms of access?
And how does the user
determine what
they're willing to share?
Because in my mind, not every
application should have access
to everything that
I do on Google+.
So how--
I know we've talked
about it before--
what is something that either
the developer has to look for,
or the user has to look for
when granting access
to an app like this?
GUS CLASS: Sure, so I'll bring
up the dialog again.
And we'll look at two
different ones.
So here is just the Google+
sign in dialogue.
And if you look on here,
there's two fields.
There's the one on the top,
underneath of the "this app
would like to." The first bar is
the information that you're
sharing with Google+.
And the information that the
application has access to, and
who has access to that
information.
So then, the second set allows
you to control who can see the
information that this
app is creating.
So if we render it again, we're
going to show it with an
additional scope now.
So here's Google Drive
and Google+.
When I click the Sign-In button,
we'll get a different
consent dialogue.
LOUIS GRAY: So now there's
three bars there.
GUS CLASS: Now there's
three bars.
So this additional bar is
requesting information to be
able to view files
and documents
in your Google Drive.
So some people get scared
when they see this.
And just by controlling how that
appears, you can allow
people to be comfortable
with sharing what
they like to share.
LOUIS GRAY: Now I think what's
critical for the user in this
case is, because you're giving
it access to Google Drive, it
explicitly calls it out.
It's not obfuscated,
it's not vague.
It says look, if you're going
to need access to Google
Drive, well by gum, here's
access to Google Drive.
And if you need access
to Google+,
here's access to Google+.
And because Google has this
shared backend of the two
systems working together,
we should
explicitly call that out.
And not just vaguely
say, Google.
And then we should let the users
know always exactly what
the applications can do.
And so while, as you mentioned,
it is more
messaging to read through, at
least the user knows exactly
what they're getting into when
they're giving an application
more accessibility.
GUS CLASS: Exactly.
So you never want to surprise
someone with information that
they haven't seen, or that they
didn't know they were
sharing with you.
Because yeah, if someone's
private information starts
getting surfaced inside of your
app, then that's going to
create all sorts of problems.
OK, so here's a consent
dialogue.
And this time I'm showing it to
enable access to my Google
Drive files.
And then, the other thing that
we'd done before was we'd
brought in the user's photos.
And now we have the photos, we
should allow them to share
those photos with people.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to render an
interactive post when a user
clicks on a particular photo.
I don't know what's going on
with my resolution, but here's
the dialogue.
And here's the share dialogue
that I've created.
So inside of here is just
this Share button.
And that is just
an HTML button.
You can take pretty much any
HTML container, and then can
render an interactive
post into that.
And I'll show you the code
in just a second.
But yeah, so this is it.
And now when I click Share, the
last set of people that I
was sharing with will appear
inside of the To field.
So this is a really
good default.
And a lot of people
start with it.
So this is a great starting
point for sharing.
And this is a great way to allow
users to have more--
whatever their last default
settings were, they just get
brought in.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, I noticed--
I'm taking a look
at this snippet.
Now, you have "this is so cute,"
which is a pre-filled
text that's on there.
And then you have a photo.
And then it says doc slash
number, number et cetera.
Now, maybe it makes sense
to a machine.
But since we're working with
social, working with humans,
how could a developer clean it
up so that that snippet is a
little bit better?
GUS CLASS: So what a developer
could do is, they can control
the way that content appears
within the stream.
And they can control the way
that app activities appear
inside of their app activities
in their application settings
by writing a snippet.
So the snippet is just
microdata, which is kind of an
annotation that is added
to markup on your page.
And those annotations can then
be tied to elements.
And then what Google does is
they calculate the way that
this will render, the way that
this will appear, based on
that microdata that's
on your page.
So for example, the
microdata on this
page is just not there.
So Google tries to do the
best that they can.
And so they may be pulling
this in from the title.
They may be pulling this
in from metadata
on the content target.
I'm not sure, specifically,
where this is coming from.
But this is a great topic,
perhaps, for a future best
practices episode.
Where we can look into improving
this experience even
more by using a snippet
and microdata.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent, cool.
I'll let you continue.
I don't want to get
in your way.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
Yeah, no problem.
So now the user can share.
And let's see how that's done.
Here's a code that's rendering
the interactive post as I'm
doing it there.
And what you need for an
interactive post is a constant
URL, which contains the
content target.
So this is what populates
the image, and so on.
And then you have a call to
action URL, which is what
happens when the user clicks the
interactive share button.
So for example, this one says
"download." And this is the
content target that will be used
when the user clicks that
Download button.
And then the last thing
that we're passing
here is people IDs.
And we'll get to that in
a second, because I'm
not using it yet.
But you can see that all of
these options are set inside
of a JSON structure.
And then they're passed to the
gapi.interactivepost.render
with the container that will
be used to contain that
interactive post.
Going back to our site, we
have this experience.
Let's make it better.
So now what I'm going to do,
is I'm going to change the
mode of the site.
And this is a live site.
So if you want to check it
out, you're welcome to.
LOUIS GRAY: And what's
the URL for this guy?
istoocute.com/#better.
That seems a little simple.
I could just do #better, and
your telling me my site
automatically gets better?
Is that what happens?
GUS CLASS: I think that
that would be a
pretty awesome feature.
And I'm pretty sure someone's
requested it already.
LOUIS GRAY: We should talk to
the Chrome team about that.
GUS CLASS: Chrome team, yes.
All right, so now we have the
same site with an experience
that's slightly different.
Now let's say that what I want
to happen, when that user
performs an interactive share,
is that it lets me know.
And it let's Louis know.
So that as curators of the site,
we can find this cute
thing, download it, and
add it to the site.
So in doing this, I think that
sharing publicly is not going
to be the right way to do it.
And also, mandating that the
user find us on Google+, or
that they have to be in circles
in order to appear
immediately within that share
dialogue, it's not as good of
an experience for the user.
So instead, now when we share,
something magical happens.
The Share button gets
rendered again.
And now Louis and I are
pre-populated inside
of the Share box.
So I'll show you how to
do this in a minute.
But let's see something
else that happens
when I click Share.
Because the interactive post
was targeted to specific
people, those specific people
will receive notifications
across Google that somebody has
shared something with them
of great relevance.
When you share something
directly with someone, you get
higher engagement because each
of those individuals will
receive notifications.
So let's see what that
notification
looks like on my machine.
If everything went
as expected.
So now this interactive post
is shared with me.
And by clicking it, I get
this experience for that
interactive post directly from
within my Google Calendar.
So this is a really powerful way
to bring users into your
app through organic
or viral growth.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's
pretty cool.
I actually got the same
notification.
I mean you sent it to yourself,
you sent it to me.
And so I have the same
capability with the same
download feature over
on my computer.
Now we're not sharing two
computers at once, just
believe it's there.
So that is pretty cool.
I mean, you basically know who
it's going to get targeted to.
You're getting a direct message,
essentially, saying
that they're getting a
notification on this post.
And I can take an action.
In this case, it was to
download that image.
And so the cute puppy or the
gopher that you were showing
goes directly to me.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So in doing that, we're able
to draw in more users.
And let's just take a look
and see how it's done.
So here is almost the
exact same code that
I showed you before.
And you'll notice, if I just
flip between the two, that
this extra line, "recipients,"
is added to the JSON that is
passed to the
gapi.interactivepost.render.
And so what you need to put into
this field of people IDs
is going to be Google
user IDs.
And these can be retrieved from
People.List, or you could
put in email addresses
directly.
And so when you do this, you're
able to either draw in
more users by email address, or
by the connections that a
user has on Google+, or directly
to an individual,
which is sort of the
non-conventional way that I've
shown it today.
So this is good.
We're targeting interactive
posts now.
And users are receiving
notifications, which is
drawing in higher engagement and
more users who are using
your app and being brought
into your app
from the Google+ stream.
Now let's see, one more way
that we can get creative.
LOUIS GRAY: How about
more awesome?
GUS CLASS: Or more awesomer.
OK, more awesome, sorry.
So let's look at one more
thing that we can do.
So again, the best practices
here are just really think
about creative ways that you
can create an experience
that's right for your site.
And for my site, let's say that
I want to have a feature
where someone can share things
that are cute with the people
who they are the most relevant
to share with.
The people that they care the
most about, or that they're
engaging with the most, or
that they're emailing the
most, and so on.
With Google+, you're
able to do this.
So let's do this share
one more time.
And now I said "share." And now
what I can do is, I can
select some people,
some specific
people, to share with.
So now what I can do is, if I
select these 10 people, or
these 5 people, or these 10
people, and click Share,
instead of that share dialogue,
those people have
been dynamically added
to the share.
LOUIS GRAY: Now That was
a pretty cool demo.
I mean, you've got avatars
of the people down below.
It automatically
fills them in.
It's not just a list of
names by text, right?
GUS CLASS: Yup.
LOUIS GRAY: And I'm kind of used
to that scenario where
you have to know the user's
explicit username.
Or you have to know their
name and you pull it
from a bit of text.
This is much more personal.
I'm going to recognize your
avatar, maybe even more than I
recognize you in real life.
Because I see you online
all the time.
And this seems like a quick way
for the user to find their
friends rapidly and
hit the buttons.
Pretty cool.
GUS CLASS: So yeah.
So you can pre-populate that.
And then up to 10 people will
receive notifications across
Google, telling them whatever
your call to action is, and
then rendering this within
their stream, and across
Google instead of that
notifications area.
So we'll look at the
code one more time.
And just to sort of see how much
I'm doing in addition to
what just the minimum is for
sharing in order to do this.
So the first thing that we
need to do is, we need to
render a picker for the best
people to share it with.
And so this is a special
feature of Google+.
And what it does is it
calculates who the best people
are across all of your friends,
and people who you've
circled and shared
with this app.
Or people who you've made
visible to this app.
And then it calculates just
who are the most relevant
people for this particular
user?
So I'm doing this API call
for Plus.People.List.
And that magic field that I'm
adding is order by best.
And I'm doing something
else here that is a
good thing to do.
And I'm filtering the content
that comes back to just
contain a URL and the user's ID,
and then their image URL.
But that's probably a topic best
saved for another best
practices session, again.
And then what I'm doing is I'm
just rendering that HTML
inside of the picker.
Now, the next thing that happens
is the last piece,
where you need to do something
extra because of this
interaction that you're
building.
And that is, you need to
re-render the Share button
inside of your page.
And so when you render that
Share button, Google will
change all the content within
there so that it's hooked up
to Google services.
So when you do that, it's
difficult to retrieve that
area again.
So what I do is, I have a
container outside of the
target container that
I then use to empty
that surrounding container.
And then I can use the same
target for that container that
I was using before.
So that pretty much
sums it up.
To sort of recap real quickly,
by targeting interactive posts
what you can do is you can
trigger those notifications
across Google.
And you can draw more users into
your apps, directly from
the Google+ stream, and directly
from the Google
notifications area.
LOUIS GRAY: Right
within your app.
And from your site.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
LOUIS GRAY: And so, one of the
questions I have as a user who
might be targeted by one of your
notifications, since I
expect I'm automatically in
your best, and we'll talk
about that soon.
But if I'm automatically
notified, do I get a
notification of which
app it was from?
Like, is this some sort of
enhanced visibility for the
developer who's application
uses this content?
Do I get to know if it came
from itstoocute.com or
whatever this project is?
GUS CLASS: Yes.
This is a great branding
opportunity when you're
rendering the interactive
post.
And you can control it through
pre-filled text.
And it'll also resurface within
other places inside of
that interactive post.
So yes.
LOUIS GRAY: So it's another way
to drive more installs,
more visibility, more access
to more people.
So it's not only better for
the application user, it's
better for the recipients of
content, and it's better for
the developers themselves.
So that's why this
is critical.
It's not just a new feature
because we could do it.
I think it's because it's
the right thing to do.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, it's the right
thing to do for users.
It's the right thing to
do for developers.
And so it's kind of a win-win
when we launched it.
We were real excited about how
this is going to improve the
experience for all the people
who are developing and
consuming products that
incorporate the Google+ platform.
So yes, very exciting.
And do you have any other
questions, Louis?
LOUIS GRAY: No I think
we answered them
right the way through.
I've seen a number of
interactive posts as this has
just rolled out.
A few applications getting
that started.
And I think every single week
when we hear from the Google+
team here on Google+ Developers
Live, we get to
understand more of the assets
that are being used, more of
the applications that are
getting into this.
And I think we're going to learn
more every single week.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
Actually, that reminds me.
We're always keeping our eyes
open for sites in the wild
that are doing these kinds of
creative things with the
Google+ platform.
Please feel free to mention me
or to mention the Google
Developers page if you're doing
something that you think
stands out and is unique.
Because I'm always delighted
when I visit a website, and
then I see them doing something
creative that really
will improve the experience for
users, and probably draw
up engagement for that
particular website.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
And I think just to piggyback
on that, I mean,
this is your show.
This is "Google+ Developers
Live." It's about you guys.
It's about making your
applications better and making
the experience better
for our users.
And so, as you find new
applications that take
advantage of Google+ Sign-In,
that take advantage of Google+
Interactive Posts, or any of the
features that are rolling
out on Google+ platform, we
want to hear about it.
And you'll probably be showcased
here on "Google+
Developers Live."
GUS CLASS: Yes.
All right well thanks
for coming in today.
And we'll be back in--
so next week we probably will
not have another "Best
Practices" episode.
I will be taking
a short break.
But the week after, or sometime
after that, I'll
probably be back with additional
best practices to
share with you guys.
So please feel free to ask
any questions in the
event and so on.
We'll try to follow
up afterwards.
And enjoy developing with
Google+ platform, and using
products that incorporate us.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks, Gus.